we're hoping to wow the family with an
amazing quick fig Jam crostini with
creamy burrata and the hearty Maine of
beef cheek Ragu with Papa Deli Big
Cheese just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah imagine the size of a
cow with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
um
yeah I always give them a really nice
season with salt and pepper on there
please so beef cheeks very cheap my cut
that takes sort of a long time to cook
yeah but give it a bit of love let it
cook in the oven it comes out like a
dream a little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored shed see
it into the pan oh cool layaway
get what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
beach beach
and then I want the onion chunky because
I'm gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurants if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half past six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours ready for lunch and the
longer you leave them in their juices
yeah and the cooking liquor the better
King eyes closed the garlic good onions
in and garlic in please nice where's
your Bailey there it is
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce I'm gonna top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water turn the gas
off and leave the lid just off at the
end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back it's solar still that's right in
the oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts Banna
cotta with that quintessentially Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of gelatin
in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
wheeze out the soaked gelatin leaves and
stir into the hot cream until completely
dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leave in the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
foreign
[Music]
crunchy hazelnut brittle nothing could
be so deliciously elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
I need it cooked we're going to now do
the Fig and brighter crostini oh okay
let's take the figs we're gonna make a
nice slightly spicy fig Jam take off the
tops yep in half and each half into
three sugar a touch of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want a bit too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they
ah what's the shape
stars star underneath taken from the
fantasy plant yeah when you dry them
like that so intensifies the flavor
really important to count how many put
in there okay yeah so one two three four
five so they're just there from flavors
that's right secret here let's get that
camera going so when I hear a jam I
don't think of caramel no but this is a
very fast Jam caramel's starting to
color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is a little sweet
vanilla I love that on my challenge got
that sort of sweet and sour flavor leave
that cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice out chapata in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it could be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread we're staying
authentically Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch of olive oil on there both sides
really important because we're going to
grill the bread push it down
put some lovely very lovely take it off
with the chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star anise pods
from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
find oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
skins disintegrated in that caramel that
looks so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty burrata
[Music]
my little money bags
looking delicious this looks fun doesn't
it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest imagine that sat there
and you tear some of that off and you
stick it on top of that and
um
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
Papa Deli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball that's going
to take that through for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
they're very soft tiny I'm going to
taste
um
it's so good
yeah you just dribbled on your jumper
really
right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta
little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom and you put
the pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
that uh what about when you cook this
for your girlfriend one day uh just tell
her where you got the recipe for money
promise promise I don't want you
stealing Daddy's Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third job and then you go
over
the sauce
how cool is that delicious you've got
the borrasa
and I've got the cheeks
let's go
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
quick fig Jam crostini with creamy
borata a main course of slow cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli and for
pudding espresso panna cotta with
cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition a delicious saffron flatbread
with mussels it doesn't get any
healthier than that first job the super
easy saffron flatbread
put the saffron into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the color
across your flatbeds to make the dough
simply add plain flour a pinch of salt
and pepper to a bowl and then pour in a
dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
Rich you're saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and then you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up
all your flour
you can see now
saffron's activated it's got that really
nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect beautiful
though
it smells delicious that saffron is a
powerful now sit that in your bowl cover
your clean film let it rest for 10 to 15
minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron I'm going to cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now lightly flour the surface
and then just
bring that
it's like a perfect ball
on the board
your rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and then just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts to
blister
is ready for turning
beautiful get that color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin it's cooked once browned
on both sides just cool on a rack
flatbread done now onto the mussels now
the secret
behind cooking
great mussels is in the speed you're
cooking
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta I want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta I
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because I want to sort of render all
that flavor
add this tricky bacon
now Tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes that's just going in
whole the garlic
just crush the garlic
it's all that flavor comes out chili
I want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked a little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
foreign
takes moments once it's brown and crisp
put your garlic chili and whole cherry
tomatoes into the pan
muscles go in
okay and I'm using dry sherry I think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage then oregano finely chopped stalks
and all I go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and see those muscles start to open lid
goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor gotta
lock in that heat the mussels will take
four to five minutes to steam in the
meantime cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch I definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
it doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steam mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]